[Music]
united airlines wants to bring back
supersonic air travel with a new
aircraft
the airline says it plans to buy 15
overture jets from the startup aerospace
company
boom supersonic boom hopes to fly a
scaled-down prototype later this year
or early in 2022 with the full-size
88-seat version
targeted to carry passengers by 2029
so what does this mean for the future of
supersonic travel is this acquisition a
turning point
or should the markets be more skeptical
united's announcement isn't a game
changer
for supersonic travel we've had pretend
orders
almost real orders before the proof is
when united
actually spends money but boom ceo blake
scholl
disputed that critique in an email to
the journal
he wrote united has agreed to purchase
15 overture aircraft on industry
standard terms
including non-refundable upfront
payments
in a statement to the wall street
journal united said
while we cannot disclose the financial
details we can confirm
that we have made a deposit which
signals our confidence in boom
as well as the aircraft they are
building
over the past decade several startups
the most prominent of which
include boom arion and spike have been
working to develop
the next generation of commercial
supersonic jets
but creating a new plane that can travel
faster than the speed of
sound and do it safely is not easy or
cheap
really this is just a question of
funding it's probably going to cost
well over 20 billion dollars to develop
a supersonic jet to say nothing of the
cost of actually
building it and buying it last month
arion which was backed by boeing
folded after it was unable to raise
enough money to produce a planned
supersonic business jet
the british french airliner concorde was
one of only two supersonic jets
to have operated commercially but it
failed as a business
because of its high ticket prices and a
2000 crash
in paris that left 113 people dead
a three and a half hour concord flight
between new york and london
cost as much as ten thousand dollars in
the year two thousand
although united has not said how much
tickets on its supersonic jets would
eventually cost
they would likely be more expensive than
a typical flight
but who is the target market they're
really two
very distinct markets the corporate
market the business jet market
typically has very low elasticity they
don't really care how much they pay for
travel
whereas uh scheduled air transport the
jetliner business the airliner business
they are typically used thousands of
hours per year obviously
that market is a bit more sensitive to
price
today business travelers have come to
expect a certain level of luxury
on their subsonic flights given the
smaller size of the supersonic planes
that same experience may be hard to
duplicate
but united isn't concerned about demand
the airline said
it believes there will be ample appetite
for supersonic trips
from business travelers concentrated in
united's coastal hubs
united told the journal boom is
designing overture
to be profitable at ferris comparable to
today's subsonic business class
thanks in large part to a 75 reduction
in operating costs
relative to concord technological
hurdles
have hampered development there was a
reason concord had 100 seats
if they could have made it bigger with
the materials available at that time and
the engines available at that time
they would have which would have made
the aircraft potentially
more economic so designers now have new
materials new engines but they still
face that basic physics which is why
the shapes are very similar between
these new designs and concord
perhaps the biggest technological
problem is reducing the sonic boom
that is made when these supersonic jets
break the sound barrier
nasa's kind of led the research in the
us and
and has a test program going on right
now
and what their researchers say that the
modelling shows that instead of a boom
that can
can break windows uh it will become what
they call a soft thump
is all that you would hear on the ground
for now
experts are skeptical about the economic
viability
of supersonic travel basically i think
boom
is feeling a bit under the gun because
of ariane's collapse the previous week
and they wanted to have something to
take to investors and say hey there's
commercial activity here
boom ceo blake scholl said that arion's
demise came as a surprise to the
industry
just a few weeks ago we couldn't
possibly conclude a transaction
in that period of time little or no
money has
has changed hands so uh united has
certainly scored a big publicity cue
whether it's advanced the technology
remains to be seen
i guess that the big help might be that
boom the aircraft
maker might find it easier to get the
kind of finance that its rivals have
found it tough to find